joker nous ce soir on a envie de faire
trois petites épreuves de fort boyard
on venait avec moi vous êtes le maître
du jeu et on va appeler isabelle morini
bosc et on appeler jean luc lemoine par
cette première
ces traitements mettez-vous là jean
pierre castaldi alors vous connaissez
cette froide mais tim mettez-vous la
preuve vous connaissez les produits
voilà alors on donne un coup de marteau
chacun à son tour sur le cloud et le
gagnant c'est celui qui l'enfoncent
complètement un clown c'est pas les
dépenses c'est la rue vous êtes sûr de
perdre alors isabelle et des tapes en
euro dames c'est parti ah ouais quand
même
et oh c'était de la rue ben voila merci
besoins des pages on n'a de merci
c'est très sain par des canettes massé
merci voilà les marteaux ou garder les
bouchers vous merci au revoir versées
sont offerts par khattab anna merci
merci attention à la vous connaissez
alors je m'appelais pour cette épreuve
je suis regardé gilbert bun je vous pose
allure non alors vous allez voir gilles
verdez ah non mais je connais aussi
gilles verdez et
et on va dire allez jean michel maire
jean michel jarre
alors il connaît tous les autres bien là
on allume le papier c'est le dernier qui
devient donc vous allez enfin la marge
brute enfin le plus longtemps
exact accord il va crever c'est
peut-être un peu dangereux ça peut être
un peu dangereux parce que je vais en
passer
oui bon d'accord il faut avec sa
s'éteignent non il faut que ça brille ça
vole ensuite j'ai plus à l'aise et j'ai
conçu excusez moi on n'a pas deux heures
chants qu'on va avoir à tous les cuire
nous on est à l'arrêt je viens et là il
a le briquet il a tout l'air parti
regardez moi cette bande de bras cassés
phase aller et je sois qu'on va voir à
tous les grilles ex aequo il a perdu en
mai
mais dites moi comment j'ai vu que ça
marche dans fort boyard est celle où
c'est une cata même si ça marche très
bien et ça marche très bien c'est gilles
verdez mais si le tien mollet révolte
ils tiennent la tête en bas jean michel
qui gagne la mélasse et jean michel qui
gagne pas ce qu'ils valent et ils valent
à l'achat mais gilles il allume rien
jamais jeune ashton non mais là j'ai dû
m'arrêter jeu tranquille night lights
allez c'est fini tu as perdu ta peur de
la perdre et hervé berne et valais faire
débat lâcher ça lâche et ç'a passé ça va
lâcher jean-michel jean-michel bravo
vous êtes sûr fera pas brouiller ses
conneries là merci merci les chéris
merci arthur merci fosc merci alors
attention voici la dernière épreuve
c'est dingue parce que dans fort boyard
c'est génial chez nous c'est pourri mais
un peu de son courrier merci
heureusement vous êtes l'agent pierre
allez on va faire la dernière épreuve je
vais appeler je fais appeler allez
christophe carrière et valérie bénard
je suis alors c'est simple
voilà les pièces le jeu consiste à
mettre chacun l'un après l'autre une
pièce dans le vert et la manche sang qui
coule dans celui qui fait couler le vert
a perdu rien c'est quoi leur âge le gars
là bas on va trouver vos acquis le
gardien de tous les jours à les hisser
partis flamands et benhaim sans rigoler
on dirait qu'elle joue pour qui veut
gagner des millions
mais des pièces
arrête
bon ça va juste revendication on
voudrait valérie attention attention
attention cantonales c'est pas très tôt
surtout nous a permis à pascal aubert
récupérer
il ya des cas plus il ya des câbles je
prends du gauche qui a lui aussi produit
le jeu ne vous inquiétez pas vous
inquiétez pas c'est non merci merci
c'est bon voilà jean pierre s'est
conclue inquiétez pas jean pierre
castaldi
voilà la nama attendait qu'est ce que je
viens de voir l'outil se cache il va
boire mais doit la montre non mais
attendez qu'ils sont venus de faire là
jean michel ménard est maintenant vous
venez de voir mon coca cacher je me suis
oui un peu vous les doigts pour soudas
oui
non mais ça et les pannes à la vie et je
voudrais vraiment que j'ai pas après
vous voulez rattraper maladie le malade
et qu'on arrête les missions les bars
bravo bravo jean michel bérard est belle
la france
comme il est bien il vient boire de chez
moi ils se cachent vous êtes terrible ça
rigolait et jean-pierre vous à fond dans
le jeu on a franchement mais ça on va
faire un truc non on va refaire pas fort
boyard on va faire fort des mythes vous
inquiétez pas
oh